I like your boyfriend very much a Jason
Sudeikis I like him too you go to one of
those Saturday Night Live after-party
where all love is born I remember I
wasn't on the dance floor and everybody
was dancing around me and they just
seemed really happy and I was just kind
of standing there for the record no one
has ever danced around me but go ahead
yes just the greatest line of all time
that Jason had she came up to me and he
said you know whatever you're looking
for you don't need it and he walked away
what the [ __ ] does that mean yeah I
would have thrown him right out the door
he was just really like cool he played
it really cool once we started like
texting a little bit really whimper
Hexter I got my number he didn't text me
for a month I was like this isn't gross
oh yeah oh you must really hear Brian
I'm worried were you checking your text
to see if he texted you like you guys
did Jason Sudeikis died because I don't
have any how does it heat up if I may
ask it was kind of sweet he didn't
literally didn't kiss me until the
fourth date that's the move toe he
finally kissed me and I was like
completely head over heels but I'll I'm
a lady so I left I got the kiss I got a
leave now this is where you got a you
know in other words you could have made
the move like hey come over and let's
let's do it yeah but you said yeah I was
like okay do you play bass game look
this like being on The Bachelor